from its original 2015 manga debuting
jump black clovers made quite the impact
us far with the latest action packed
season being so impressive we'll be
going through the 10 greatest moments of
the anime so far now this list isn't
just fights and battles but anything
that had us on the edge desperately
wanting to see what would come next so
sit back relax and let's recount what's
made black clover great and memorable so
far
[Music]
we start off at the beginning of the
series with hasta awakening his Grimm or
a star was born with no special magical
talent but in his fight with rev G he
finds out that he has a grimoire that
gives him the abilities he's always
dreamed of able to create swords from
his grimoire aster realizes that he can
use the swords to cast anti magic an
ability that allows him to nullify other
forms of magic and with his new grimoire
appearing on himself he's not only able
to defend himself against rev G and
defeat him but he's also able to follow
the dream of becoming a magic knight
with this the story of asters quest to
become the magic Emperor begins
so
[Music]
coming in at number nine we have a star
facing off against Mars with you know
nearly being killed by Mars asked the
jumps in to defend his foster brother at
first it appears he's put Mars out of
commission quickly however after healing
himself an immobilizing asked his allies
inside the Treasury the true fight
between Mars and aster is about to begin
as the fight rages on asked her picks up
a new sword and uses it to gain the
upper hand against the diamond kingdoms
night still aster can't make any lasting
damage thanks to Mars his fire healing
right as Mars is about to kill aster
he's taken out by a winged girl ending
the fight with neither character having
completely defeated the other
[Music]
next the number eight we have no LC
dragon war versus vet Oh at the defeat
of kaha no and Kioto Noelle's terrified
to attack the powerful veto but with
words of encouragement from the fallen
kaha No
Noelle releases her magic and takes
better warm confident in his own
abilities veto urges her to use her most
powerful attack telling her he's sure to
send it right back to her Noelle fires
sea dragons roar which is more powerful
than vetto assumed taking his right arm
off
[Music]
damn anybody from the Sun look at
suitable thank you
[Music]
to number Seven's none other than Yami's
dark cloak dimension slash as Astor
Vanessa and Finn rule believed they've
defeated Vito the black balls hope that
that's the end of it however it isn't
and Beto stands up ready to fight again
before anything can happen
Yami breaks through the spatial magic
and hits Vetter with a powerful attack
unleashing his dimension slashing magic
this time sending the elf down for good
[Music]
[Music]
you children assume that they'll have a
was that some open
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Venessa awakening the red thread of fate
is at number six
after years of mistreatment at the hands
of the witch Queen Vanessa had found her
true family in the black balls when her
family was being threatened she was
willing to put it all on the line in
order to save them begging her grimoire
to change fate vanessa is greeted by a
red cat made of thread and a new spell
in her grimoire deciding to test
Vanessa's new magic the Queen gets asked
her to cut Noelle's head off but misses
every time even after ordering asked her
to try and harm the other members of the
black balls none of it works and fate
itself seems to be changing
seeing as Vanessa's new magic something
that she believes belongs to her the
Queen attempts to control Vanessa but as
she does so the cat jumps on to the
Queen and renders her magic useless
allowing aster and company to take on
the Queen and set Vanessa free from her
past once and for all
Nanoha Ricardo Kanishka micachina but
that's dawn at any given an antenna
certitude excessively doesn't send you
home does
next to number five we have Yami versus
Lynch wanting to test his magic out
against the dark magic user which
delightfully takes on the challenge that
is Yami
despite Lich's quick casting of several
spells Yami is able to deflect them
showing how powerful the dark mages Yami
eventually decides that it's time for
him to go all out against his strong
opponent and releases his mana
despite this Lich's still easily able to
deflect Yami's attacks as the fight
rages on lych fires a spell but gosh
shows up and reflects the spell back
defeating lid
[Music]
I'm you know who it's um
[Applause]
Cosimo
kuna come out the Tomika coming in at
number 4 we have you knows victory over
ill earning him the title of victor of
the tournament despite being frustrated
for not being able to face a stir in the
final match you know still prepares
himself to give it his all in order to
win at the fight begins you know takes
on brill as his teammates defend his
crystal this was easily one of the best
animated fights from the series you know
quickly finds out how reals able to
easily defend himself from his magic
seeing this you know decides it's time
for him to use his trump card coating
himself in spirit magic you know attacks
real who's already forming a counter
creature to attack you know so absorbed
into the fight and you knows abilities
real breaks his crystal by mistake and
this is the move that would later make
you knows team victorious ending the
tournament with you know as the victor
[Music]
it
creature suitable crudo
oh cool
[Music]
number three is none other than the
black balls versus Beto with Vito
quickly outnumbered by the black balls
it's clear to them that their opponents
going to be defeated soon so as long as
the balls work together despite this
Vetter makes the fight a longer hard one
from Noelle's supporting her friends to
Vanessa
federal and asters teamwork Vetter
starts struggling to keep up with a
sword already having drained a lot of
Vito's magic ask the breaks through
Vito's armor and delivers a final blow
[Music]
[Music]
at number 2 we have julius facing off
against lich with lit suspecting that
judas carries the final two stones he's
seeking a fight between the two
experienced men begins it appears that
the two could be evenly matched
however the stand still matches quickly
turned in Lich's favor when he releases
his sealed magic in cast a spell that
would harm those in the kingdom as this
happens judas is reminded of how he
always thought zara was a true magic
knight and that he had to do something
to stop this attack on his people not
wanting harm to come to them julius uses
his time magic to erase Lich's spell
this was the perfect moment for lich to
strike and with a blade of light cuts
julius down commenting how the magic
emperor's weakness was being the magic
emperor
Maho TDR Pato Sarika oh my no you is no
joke Tilda
encima de chile you know go to chemo not
inari Oh magician an Chima on your easy
road
[Music]
[Music]
at number one we have asked their
awakening his demon form in his fight
against land Ross Astor is quickly
overwhelmed by the magic and abilities
lad Ross holds and right when he's sure
he's delivered the final blow and broken
down asked his spirit with his words
asked those arms consumed by a black
mass now this black mass forms our blade
and a wing and a stir quickly uses his
new ability to his advantage lad Ross is
left speechless and soon defeated with a
powerful blow from Astor
[Music]
whether it's in manga or anime form
black clovers for sure a series that
everyone should check out seeing as it
has a bit of everything for even the
pickiest of anime watchers won't be in
your favorite moments from the series so
far and what do you think we may have
missed on our list let us know in the
comments below thanks so much for
watching this video be sure to leave a
like subscribe for more great anime
content and turn on those Bell
notifications that you never miss a
single one of these videos I'll see you
next time on vinnie tube
[Music]
[Applause]